foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where
people where we help people build wealth
do work that they love and have actual
amazing relationships I'm John deloney
joined by my great friend Jade warshaw
and we are taking your calls on money
life work your mental and emotional
health your marriage whatever you got
going on in your life we may not have a
great answer but we will sit here with
you and we will help you figure out the
next right step triple eight eight two
five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
roll out to the 505 in Albuquerque New
Mexico and talk to Mary what's up Mary
yeah hey hey it's a pleasure to be part
of your program I have a question for
you bring it on I'm so glad that you're
with us what's up all right my husband
and I applied for a home mortgage but we
pulled out uh when we realized the house
payment was going to be more than half
our monthly income
so now we are like traumatized when we
think about going into the housing
situation the housing market
we need help and what should we do why
are you traumatized it sounds like you
made a really smart move
well we did because we figured there's
no price on our peace of mind and so we
did make a wise move but now we're like
okay now what yeah because you realize
you dodged a bullet you realized what
could have almost just happened right
you're right wow that's a good way of
putting it you know look
um what I try to do uh my husband and I
have bought two homes together
um and we've tried to get as much
information at the jump as possible so
we're out there researching we're using
all of the mortgage calculators so what
I would suggest for the next time going
in is uh use a mortgage calculator and
we have a great one it's how much home
can I afford right and you can put in
the numbers of the homes that you're
finding in your area that you think
might be the one right and then you're
using your income and you're looking at
what that monthly payment is going to be
now you knew that in this case it was
way too much right you knew 50 was too
much what we'd want you to get to is
um a mortgage where the pay payment is
no more than 25 percent of your
take-home pay after taxes all right it
doesn't have to be after uh medical
insurance and after 401k contribution
that sort of thing just your take-home
pay after taxes and of course we want
you on a 15-year uh fixed rate mortgage
now here's the other thing because I'll
be honest I don't think we always talk
about this enough John
um you need your down payment you know
we're looking for five to twenty percent
of the down payment but then you also
have to think about things like earnest
money
closing costs moving costs there's so
much to consider when you're buying a
home
um
take your time that's all I can say does
that help you at all
yeah take your time how much time more
or less do you think 50 to 60 years I
mean like Mary tell me tell me like you
you seem genuinely like rattled
yeah well I am because we put down the
earnest money two thousand dollars and
we were excited about it but we didn't
do it I think everything that you're
saying a lot of the research and a lot
of the uh moving costs and the extra
costs that we didn't take into
consideration we got emotionally
involved yeah brand new house and we
were brand new couple we just got
married and we were ready to move in and
then I woke up one morning I said wait a
minute wait a minute I think you also
feel bad because you made the offer and
had to rescind it as well is there
something there yeah we we lost the two
thousand dollars in earnest money hey
that was the best two thousand dollars
you've ever spent you got lucky you got
lucky
um I would do exactly what Jay did and
and said to do and write this stuff down
and probably do it over
um like a Grody ooey gooey newlywed like
breakfast together on a Saturday morning
and let's be all lovey-dovey and let's
be also clear-eyed and say okay we
already think this is going to cost and
this is going to cost and this is going
to cost and then you're gonna have to
own reality here's how much house we can
actually buy right now we had this dream
of this house and this is not going to
happen especially not in Albuquerque
where prices have gone b-a-n-a-n-a-s but
we're going to find that we can afford
this house what if we let's just rent
for a year or we can afford this house
let's go let's go get our realtor um on
on the trail and that that actual data
that information
combined with you leaning in to your
husband not away from each other right
now because there's this awkward little
Rift in your marriage right now because
you probably want to keep on going
through it and you said no it helps heal
all of that and it will bring down the
temperature inside your chest
yes
so let's just get real information and
real data by the way here both Jaden I
say
you not only made the right call
you
um you did what I think is really hard
which is stop a moving train and most of
us are just like well I've already had
this donut so my diet is shot for the
month or I missed this morning's workout
so I guess I'll just work out next year
and you stopped halfway said no no no
this isn't who I want to be this is not
how I want to start our marriage so I
want you to hear Jade and I applauding
you we're super proud of you thank you
what you did wasn't a failure what you
did was a last second what are we doing
and you and you did you did it and again
this is not this was not a no you know I
don't want you to think oh man we we
messed this up so that means we can't
have a house it's just not yet right so
you asked John like how long is this
process going to take when are we gonna
get there and the answer is when you get
there you'll get there when you get
there when you've got the money saved
when you've got the research under your
belt when you find the right home that
meets the criteria that's when you're
ready it doesn't have to do with
interest rates or you know when when the
economy says it's a good time to buy
right the good time to buy is when you
are financially ready to buy something
to clear up um what may be another
question Mary my wife and I we don't
live in our Dream Home
we don't and our home is awesome
and our marriage is good and watching my
kids smile every day is awesome and so I
think our obsession with
um is this perfect is this the forever
what about in 10 years are we gonna dude
10 years ago I was three jobs and two
states away from here 10 years is a
million years ago
sit down and do the data right in front
of you and say over the next two to
three to five years I think we think
this is what this might look like for us
this is awesome take you you feel like
you've got a lot of pressure on your
shoulders man as the great Jay-Z said
just brush your shoulders oh get that
Dirt Off Your Shoulders come on John
does that make sense Mary
yes totally totally it makes so much
sense because it's based on facts
information and so that's the basis of
making good decisions for me and if you
watch the news
most people don't make decisions based
on facts and so you are living in a rare
air you you decided to head out on your
own
um jade you're you are have been running
the media Gauntlet talking to
um people and uh running live streams
you've been you've been meeting with
people talking to Media folks what is
the pulse there with a living in fact
right yeah I mean right now look John
credit card debt is higher than it's
ever been a trillion dollars student
loans are coming back a Trill it sounds
like you're a kid making a joke
trillion dollars I have to stutter when
I say it because it's crazy then we've
got student loan debt that's 1.67
trillion right most people's payment is
somewhere between three to five hundred
dollars that's just for their you know
federal student loans and then you got
the car payments people are starting to
fall on their car payments this is
catching up to us and then on top of
that we're all saying yeah but I want to
buy a house too
something's got to give you've got to
live in the reality of your situation
and figure out what you've got to do to
solve for it right you can't keep things
as they are and still get XYZ you've got
to start making changes and doing
something different if you want to get
something different with a trillion with
a t t
trillions gives me the hemorrhoids we'll
be right back on the Ramsey Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
either one
their wash and guarantee and
see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
50 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm John deloney
joined by Jade warshaw and we're taking
your calls on money and life and
relationships in your mental emotional
health your work whatever you got going
on Triple eight eight two five five two
two five the question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services neighborly.com is the
place to find Reliable help for your
home from a locally owned businesses
like air serve dryer vent wizard
Precision garage door service God I need
them at my house right now Wendy window
Genie and more for expert help with just
about anything you need visit
neighborly.com that's right today's
question comes from Irene in Texas
hey yeah I like that she says this is
probably a long shot in reaching out
since I'm sure everyone does but I'm
pretty much drowning in debt as
embarrassing as it is to say that I'm
handling my credit cards car and private
student loans using your methods as best
as I can but when it comes to federal
student loans my anxiety kicks in
especially now that the payments will
restart again and by the way interest
starts today I have about 192 000 an
astronomical amount in interest as is
part of that sum in student loans and I
don't know where to get the correct info
on how to pay it I feel like everyone
has a different take and it's hard to
know what move to make so that I don't
add any more to the debt any help on how
to move forward with this is greatly
appreciated I just can't afford 2K
payments every month which is probably
what they will want me to pay all right
John let's let's get comfortable right
here because we're going to unpack this
um number one Irene you're not alone
that's the first thing I want you to
understand here is thank you for this
question because you asking this is
about to give Solutions and answers for
a lot of people so thank you so much for
that
um 192 000 in in federal student loans
plus other debt obviously you guys know
interest starts today with payment
starting
in October whenever your payment is due
in October and she's going to be one of
those people so there's a lot of
misinformation out there and it can be
confusing okay Irene so the first thing
I want you to do and this for anybody
listening you need to find who's got
your loan okay because most of the loan
providers that were out there before
covid they've decided student loan
business sucks we're out and so your
loan has been sold to somebody else all
right so you need to find who that is
whether it's moella whether it's uh
Granite State or whatever that one is
called Great Lakes all of these
different ones it's no longer Sallie Mae
right there's all these other service
providers so you need to
answer your correspondence right if
you're getting letters in the mail if
you're getting emails like don't bury
your head in the sand open that bad boy
up and see what's going on call the
1-800 number and I posted about this on
social the other day yeah you might be
on hold for a minute and this might take
a couple of lunch breaks to get this
thing done but uh Don't Tap Out simply
because it's taking longer than you
hoped you need to find out what's going
on all right next part to that is you're
going to talk to a student loan rep and
they're going to act like they know
what's best for you and I'm telling you
right now they are a customer service
expert they are not a finance or money
expert okay and I can tell you this they
barely understand what's going on okay
so when they start saying oh we could do
a an icr plan or an ibr plan or a save
planner and they start saying all these
things they're gonna suggest the one
that they know the most about okay not
what's necessarily best for you so
A1 is I want you to be able to make your
payment okay so when you open up that
envelope or you log into the screen and
you go oh 221 I can do that if you can
do it great keep it like that if you
look at that payment and you're like
holy crap if I do that we don't get to
eat now is the time to start thinking
about okay how can I make this minimum
payment lower all right so that that's
the only time if it's keeping you from
eating
lower your payment and get a smaller
minimum temporarily now in this case
with Irene hold on that means some
people are going to have to sell their
house because they bought a house two or
three years ago and they owed 300 000
and they thought that was all going to
go away and it didn't yeah that means
some people have to move Apartments what
you're saying is not if you're gonna
have to adjust your lifestyle a lot then
see if you can lower the payment no no
yes you want the payment as high as you
can possibly get it or you can still
make that payment well there's a there's
a piece to that John so if you're if
you're working a debt snowball like
Irene or like Sam and I for instance and
you've got a bunch of other debts in
your student loans like it's interesting
because her her payments are two
thousand dollars my husband and I our
student loan payments alone or two
thousand dollars we could not make those
payments even with a Bare Bones budget
so what we did in the only way the only
only in Big Red Letters bold underlined
with lots of exclamation points okay
hear me on this the only way I would
entertain a payment plan to lower my
minimum payment is if I'm intensely
working a debt snowball because in the
debt snowball if anybody doesn't
understand this you're listing all of
your debts smallest to largest you're
making minimum payments on everything
and then your extra money you need extra
money to throw out the smallest debt now
in the midst of this you're working
extra jobs you are not going out to eat
you are not having a life because you're
paying off your debt and if that can
help you get leverage the same way we
say hey lower your your withholding you
know so you're not getting a tax return
so you have extra money the same way we
say hey temporarily pause your 401k
contribution to get extra money all of
this stuff all of this guidance is
contingent upon you doing the plan
because if you're going to lollygag and
you're gonna kick rocks and be like ah
well you know I'll do a little here a
little there then you pausing your
retirement you're screwing yourself you
doing an IDR plan you're screwing
yourself you have to do this with the
intent of I am paying off my debt and
I'm doing this with intensity and
intentionality and it is not simply to
Kick the Can down the road and hope that
20 to 25 years from now there's some
kind of you know bucket of forgiveness
so
and how am I supposed to just not go out
then yes yes oh am I supposed to just go
like for hikes with on with the person
I'm dating yes yes
that's all you can afford that's all you
can afford because at the end of the day
um Irene when it comes to this you get
on the phone you talk to this person
they're gonna say hey why don't you do
this plan why don't you do that plan or
by the way here's the newest thing uh 12
month on ramp
12 month on-ramp says Hey when payments
resume in October if you're not ready to
pay don't pay
and will allow the interest to accrue
yes because we're going to get our money
because again
federal student loans they want your
payment they don't want your piece okay
so they're gonna let that interest
accrue but oh how nice of them we just
won't tell the credit bureau that you're
defaulting so we're just not going to
report it and for a year you can go on
and let that interest accrue as though
we're doing you a favor it's like a
medical doctor saying you know what
we're just gonna keep taking your blood
tests and putting them in a shredder for
a year you eat however you want to smoke
whatever you want drink whatever you
want it's all good we're just gonna put
your blood test you're still gonna die
you're still gonna die you're still
gonna die and let me tell you guys
something because
I don't think John people I don't think
their brain and their heart and their
mind will let them accept the fact that
they can be free you can pay off these
student loans it's not a myth it's not
mythical what Irene is talking about I
know that situation my husband and I had
280 000 of student loans part of them
were federal student loans a big chunk
and a big chunk were private variable
interest rates okay like I said before
one of the loans was 192 thousand
dollars and the payment on it was nine
hundred dollars on that one loan I'm
getting choked up just talking about it
because I know how that mess feels so
don't wait around you have to be free I
don't care if they tell you the interest
is not accruing if they tell you well
forgive it after 25 years your body
feels that mess your marriage feels that
she says my anxiety kicks in it should
it should that's your body telling you
you're not safe because you're not
because you're not
and I've lived it too me and Sheila
we've both lived it
say that again
ex like um I think we say peace a lot
and I don't even know that we have a
psychology for that anymore yeah
walk people through the back end of this
like what it actually feels like when
there's all this tussling going into
Washington and you just you just keep
swiping because it doesn't it doesn't
apply to you yeah look the goal is to
get above the radar right where you're
just flying above you're like an eagle
man you you're looking and you're going
what's going on down there oh man okay
I'm glad I don't have nothing to do with
that that's what it is on the other side
of this on the other side of Freedom you
have forgiveness for yourself
for yourself because so many of you guys
feel like man I can't believe I let the
government trick me I got swindled into
this and it's like man was I was I
seriously that dumb no you weren't you
made a bad choice but when you pay off
your debt you get forgiveness and you
get peace and you get Freedom with your
money that's what this is all about not
waiting for somebody to be a hero you're
your own hero go get your freedom get it
out get your peace get it Irene in the
Republic of Texas make it happen we'll
be right back on the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
over your head with student loans and
tired of getting calls from collection
agencies if private student loan debt is
taking away your financial peace and you
don't see any way out you need why refi
they're not a debt settlement company
and they're not connected to a bank why
refi refinances defaulted private
student loans that other places won't
touch and gives you a custom loan built
for you based on your ability to pay so
when you refinance your private student
loan debt with why refi you'll have a
payment you can afford with a low fixed
interest rate you couldn't get anywhere
else to help you stick to your budget
and work the debt snowball and you can
save thousands of dollars to learn more
about this custom refinancing option and
a lump sum payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call 844-2
Ram MZ or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsey Show I'm John
deloney joined by Jade warshaw and we
are taking your calls let's roll out to
D-Town Dallas Texas and talk to Bianca
what's up Bianca
hi thank you so much for taking my call
today thanks for thanks for calling us
what's up
I am a 27 year old I am about fifty
thousand dollars in debt
um I want to start saving and investing
from a future if and if things are good
buy a house uh sometime soon
um what should I do how do I start
planning I just started listening to
your show about two weeks ago Welcome to
our gang
we are a bunch of weirdos but we're
happy to have you part of us we're glad
glad you joined us so hey Bianca I love
that you have all these goals I think
it's great I want you to have a house
one day I definitely want you to invest
for your future
um so I love that you're thinking about
this
um you're fairly new to the gang I would
say so I kind of just let's bring it
back to the basics and kind of walk
through the why of what we do and then
talk a little bit about
um what the what of what we do and then
talk about why we do that so if you're
new we walk through the series of seven
baby steps right so the first baby step
is getting a thousand bucks saved right
most Americans have no money saved and
so as a result they depend on the credit
cards and so we want to make sure that's
not the case let's keep a little money
aside and then the second baby step is
we're paying off all of our debt except
our home mortgage and the reason we're
doing that is because when you have your
income freed up when you have your money
back and you're no longer making a bunch
of payments then you actually have the
money to do things like invest save for
a down payment on a home that sort of
thing so we're paying off all of our
debt and then we're saving up because a
thousand dollars it got us by but we
need more savings than that right so
we're saving up three to six months
expenses
and then it's like all right
everything's set I've got this nice
cushy emergency fund I can get a house
if something goes wrong with the house
the AC goes out I've got money to handle
it I'm not having to go on to credit
cards and if you know the car breaks
down I don't have to get a 401k loan you
know what I'm saying so we're setting
ourselves up to be able to have savings
invest buy a home
um in the most efficient uh safest
possible way does that make sense yeah
so right now would you not start would
you not begin investing I wouldn't hold
off on this I would hold off on it um I
know I'll be honest a lot of people are
like clutch my pearls she told me not to
invest it's only temporary that's the
oldest thing I've ever heard somebody
say what Clutch my pearls yeah
I'm an old soul you're really I'm from
the old school I know
um so yeah it's temporarily just
remember it's temporary we're doing this
all with intensity we're doing it
quickly and John will tell you most
people who walk through this path Bianca
they're done 12 24 36 months they're
finished with their debt what's your
income by the way
so I currently make 105 105 000 a year
now wait is it just you
just me hey hey hey Bianca crushing it
I'm excited because if you live on 55
000 this year you're a debt free this
year
I'm trying to
um so just uh as soon as I started
listening to you guys I cut out all of
my subscriptions and um I mean I'm
trying to limit myself to really save up
as much as I can just because I feel
like I've fallen behind I feel like I
should have a lot more saved I feel like
I just should just have a lot more and
and so I'm trying to catch up a very
common thing we hear is I realized I
make way too much money to be this broke
yeah and you're a single 27 28 year old
making six figures
so think of it this way all the things
that you laid out I want to pay this
debt off I want to start investing I
want to buy a house Jade Knight 100 want
that for you
we just know after millions of people
have have walked alongside us over the
years
um
there's an order to it and if you do it
out of order
um then things get sideways your air
conditioner will break your transmission
will fall out of your car coveted will
happen and your five real estate
properties that you've leveraged will
not have to pay rent and whatever comes
up
um do you have how many how much cash do
you have
so I have about 10 15 000 States you you
are going to be so puckered up
when we tell you to send 14 000 of that
to this debt and you're instantly down
to what thirty six thousand
and you'll have 1 000 bucks and listen
you're gonna feel so angsty and that's
the point
we want you to not feel like you can sit
down until you are debt free because
you're not safe you make six figures and
you're still not safe
you are one wrong laugh at the wrong
joke at work and your boss tells you to
leave then you lose your house and your
car and your you see what I'm saying
your body's doing its job by not letting
you feel comfortable when you owe this
kind of money
okay so good on a thousand bucks dump 14
Grand of that 15 towards your debt today
knock off some of those credit cards in
order of of at least and you might
consider selling your car and buying a
Camry to get around Dallas in whatever
you got to do and you're gonna find real
fast that you're scratching claw and
scratching claws you're not gonna owe
anybody anything then you save up that
emergency fund where you're your own
bank
and then you're off to the races yeah
Bianca when you're 30 you're going to
have a house and you're going to be
investing and you're going to have been
in that Rhythm for a while and you're
going to look back on this and go oh my
God I'm so glad that I started the day
that they told me to start
I'm excited does that make sense it does
yeah I appreciate you guys so much no
thank you so much hey and keep us um
keep us apprised of your journey let us
know how it goes the good stuff the bad
stuff the hard stuff but um I love
hearing these the the the steps along
the way I know the debt free screams are
the end but I love hearing these things
along the way
um let's run out to John in Jacksonville
what's up John
hey guys what's going on thanks for
taking the call we are partying man
what's up hey
question um I'll try to give you the
short version of
our long story but we basically have um
80 000 in savings that we're trying to
save for our next uh home a larger home
and a nicer Community but we have two
vehicles with a total debt of 62 000 on
those John
so I kind of know what was coming when I
took this call we still wanted to reach
out to you guys so my wife's hiding in
the other room she should be hiding
what's your income John
um so we're fortunate enough where she's
staying home with our our new son uh
the income from me is about 150 a year
okay
um so that's where we're sitting with
that uh we had a long story with our our
son getting him getting home from the
hospital when he was born but
needless to say we were just thinking
that we obviously know what we need to
do with this money instead of saving it
and using it for our next step we just
really wanted to make sure talking to
y'all that we know we're the only debt
we have is the cars here's the question
I would challenge you on
are those cars in your driveway
and by the way I I remember the car that
I drove my daughter home from the
hospital in it was an old Prius and I
remember it only because it had it had a
crazy ice storm and I didn't think we're
gonna make it I do not remember the car
I drove my son home in I have no
recollection of that car so the question
I would have you and your wife ask each
other is are these two cars
worth not having a home because I do
remember the homes we brought our kids
home
right
and then they make 150 Grand but if you
make 150 Grand and your wife loves you
who cares if you're driving an old
Corolla well let me hit him with another
side unless you and me me and John are
going to give you two opposing views how
about that Ramsay first
[Laughter]
so John is saying hey if you want a
house you got 62 in card debt pay those
Joker you know sell those Jokers and you
know you have the money I'm looking at
this number and I'm going okay 150 you
get you know you got 62 000 in cars
that's probably 30 something each for
each of your cars they probably are
about worth what you owe on them is that
is that right
um like you're not upside down anymore
are you upside down on either of them uh
no no so my thought is like if you love
The Cars it's not more than half of your
you know annual income if you love The
Cars you could keep them but the
sacrifice would be it's going to take
you longer to get your home
so you have to just decide what do you
value most that's what J that's what I
would say neither is wrong that's right
that's why I love the question yeah I
just try to think of my son who's five
saying Daddy why don't we have a house
and me saying because we need a camera I
had this red truck that made me feel
tough and he'd go but Daddy can I have a
room so that's just how I look at it but
also I'm not a car guy so I can teach
his own but yeah there's not a wrong
path here
um but make it happen quick John we'll
be right back
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsay show if you are
new to this gang of weirdos
those decided to take both pills and get
out of the Matrix and stop letting Banks
and credit card companies and car
dealerships run our lives
if you want to dive deeper into the
Ramsay baby steps and figure out what
the world we're even talking about go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the next best step for your financial
Journey based exactly where you are
right now I know it's easy to listen to
folks and be like yeah but what about
the we got you go to ramseysolutions.com
and click on get started and we'll get
you hooked up all right let's go out to
Denver Colorado where it's all legal and
talk to Kaylee Kaylee
what's up that's for sure hi thank you
both for taking my call today you bet
how we doing
very good I hope you both are the same
um I'm calling because I am wondering if
we should make interest-free monthly
payments on a home repair or use our
emergency fund to partially pay it off
we are in baby step three we have about
30 or 5 300 saved up but our actual
fully funded emergency fund is around
ten thousand
um but we had a swamp cooler go out and
it actually was nine thousand dollars to
get repaired and the company set us up
with interest-free payments but now I'm
not sure do I just roll this back into
like it's debt or do we continue to put
into our emergency fund and still just
make the monthly payments without any
interest
let me make sure I understand uh you had
ten thousand in your fully funded
emergency no we're on baby step three
working towards the goal of ten thousand
okay oh okay so you've got 53 you're
you've only got 53 at this point
yes exactly got it and how much is it
going to cost to get the repair in total
well we had to get it done because we
had been putting it off for several
years but it finally started gushing
water into our basement and so we've
already got it payments start this month
okay so there's no going back you've
already gotten into this and how much
what's the amount I had to do it it was
starting to ruin our house our our walls
all of it shoot what was the amount
nine thousand nine thousand okay
um I
you're in it now so yeah you gotta treat
it like debt you gotta pay it off
um okay and you're back you're
essentially back in baby step one
um and that sucks but it does it does
and uh you know you called in so I gotta
I gotta whoop you a little bit because
I'm like no whenever stuff like this
comes
guys uh we gotta take debt off the table
we've gotta yeah yeah take it off the
table we did have it coated last year
for and they it was only thirty five
hundred dollars last year like oh okay
great so we'll save up to that and so we
finally bit the boat we're like oh let's
get him out here and fix it and it ended
up being way more than that did you get
more than one definitely more than one
um personal look at it
we did that was like middle of the road
what do you think John
um
here here's
I I think this is a make or break for
you guys and I'm not saying that being
over dramatic but y'all had this big
moment we're gonna get out of debt we're
gonna go through these baby steps and
then you had the you got hit in the
mouth the first time
and it was you got hit hard and
um
y'all are going to be dealing with both
the fact that you owe 4 700 more than
you got and
that you all made an agreement together
and for whatever reason we had to had to
whatever we did it and so this is one of
those make or break moments for for this
journey and I just sat with enough
people to tell you the first big rattle
out of the bag the the guy who you know
I'm never eating sugar again and then he
finds himself with his grandma's cookies
headed towards his mouth like he's got
this is a moment right so if I'm you and
I am you're married right
yes okay is your spouse on board
yes yeah I mean okay so no that's no not
even a long process to be honest this is
a long process we've got hit in the
mouth actually quite a few times this is
probably amazing
maybe our second
technology funded emergency fund and
then we gotta go back yeah so okay hold
on hold on for him it's like it's like
yeah we got there and then something
comes up and then it's like okay we have
to get back on this okay okay but hold
on this is what it's for because think
about if you didn't have the emergency
fund that's right you'd have thirty
thousand dollars in credit card debt
right now
so people get frustrated I just filled
it up and then this thing happens and I
just filled it up this thing happens and
I just want to scream yes it's exactly
what it's for frustrating and it won't
keep happening unless you are like Tom
Hanks in The Money Pit like it won't
keep happening but thank God thank God
you've been doing this work so that
every time it shows up you've got a plan
I would treat this like I would
lock arms with my spouse
and I would treat this outstanding 4 700
bucks like it's on fire
yeah okay let's do 90 days we Uber on
the way to work we Uber on the way home
from work we work on Saturdays we work
on Sundays let's go
b-a-n-a-n-a-s get this out
yeah let's not I'm definitely feeling it
like so many times we're like okay we're
done with that we're done with that and
then this pops up and I'm like oh that's
that's right I want you to fully digest
that this is not just a math problem
here this is a we made an agreement and
we went backwards
and so there's going to be a shame
component to that kick that in the teeth
by y'all making a Berserker attack on
this 4 700 bucks we did it yeah I'm not
going to rely on some HVAC company to
float my family we're gonna knock this
thing out quick okay see what I'm saying
yeah I thought that was going to be the
answer and I just like
a trading
back and go back and go back but it is
but here I'll say thank God thank God
thank God I don't want it hanging over
our head and you haven't gone back you
stayed you stayed above water
okay so you would be at the bottom of
the ocean if you had not had these
emergency had these emergency funds over
and over again yeah yeah for sure for
sure so thank you thank you for that uh
confidence boost
ER you know it's interesting when people
set out to walk the baby steps they set
out to pay off their debt you are it's
it's counter-cultural right it's people
use credit cards and they use debt and
they go on zero and you know payments
with no interest interest for however
many months and and that's what people
do but when you say I'm not going to
live my life like that I'm gonna uh give
myself credit that we can live on what
we make and we can use cash and we don't
need credit you meet resistance like
that's just part of it you can't avoid
it and so I like what John said like
you're gonna encounter emergencies
you're gonna have resistance you're
gonna have things that are gonna try to
knock you off course those shouldn't be
a signal of oh I must be doing something
wrong I'm making a mistake it's not
working that's actually a signal that
you're doing right because you did you
don't just run to the credit card that's
you know break it out of the block of
ice right in in the freezer you didn't
just run you know what I'm saying that
is a signal that okay you're doing
things different because you have to
start digging deep to find Solutions do
we need to sell the couch
do I need to sell the lawnmower what do
I need to do to get this money so that
I'm not going back to debt I'm gonna win
and debt is always going to try to
wrestle you to the mat and get you to
tap out but you've gotta you gotta do
you know all an old high school
wrestling move and get back on top and
not let debt cause you to tap okay this
is it yeah and let me give it like you
just nailed it I want to make sure
people get the the level here my little
brother sold his dream dream dream five
string Music Man Stingray custom bass
that he had built so him his wife could
get out of debt I remember when my wife
and I were going and I got rid of my all
my Martin Acoustics I got rid I sold
them because because Freedom was more
important than stuff I drove a 1993 Ford
F-150 as the dean of students at a law
school and my colleagues would laugh
because it was embarrassing right it was
a tough truck as well and you guys
didn't have a mattress for eight years
right we sold our bath mats at one point
on Facebook Marketplace somebody paid
six dollars for a bath mats right so
here's I want you to hear us that's the
intensity of the people you're talking
to you can find a friend
right now that would tell you oh it
doesn't matter if you want to listen to
that friend knock your lights out but
you called us and we're gonna tell you
the truth get this out of your life get
out of your life get out of your life
you are winning even when you feel like
you're not you are hey that's the first
hour in the books thank you so much to
the guys in the booth even will we're
grateful will and Scott Kylie is thank
you America we'll be right back on the
Ramsay show
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
talk about your money and your work and
your mental and emotional health pretty
much everything I'm John deloney joined
by Jade warshaw and we're taking your
calls on money and work and life and
love all of it triple eight eight two
five five two two five it's triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go out to Canada and talk to the one and
only Carl what's up Carl
hi there how are you fantastic how about
you
good I'm well uh lots of questions so
I'm gonna throw them right at you so
bring them on man bring them on
I'm wondering whether to carry on
renting or airport coaches a property so
essentially uh just got on the Ramsay
about a week ago uh read The Total Money
Makeover in like two days I'm like okay
drink the Kool-Aid let's go so welcome
to the group welcome to the cult welcome
to the cult thank you
so I'll throw some numbers at you so
basically uh I didn't have an emergency
phone so I just made an emergency fund
so I got about five months worth of
emergency now I got 150 000 in savings
um my current rent is about just short
of three thousand dollars a month
um
to purchase something that would be
equivalent to what I rent and to be
honest not even quite as good as what I
rent I would be looking up something
around the 750 000 mark
um
I was looking at purchasing things
before I found Ramsay and I was looking
at 25-year mortgages because that's just
what people do apparently and then when
I saw your 15-year kind of
recommendation you know put a few
calculations in it ended up like the
mortgage would be like 4 800 a month or
something like that so then it ended up
being well over my kind of 25 type thing
what's your income I'm wondering but
because so between me and my wife where
like the full tax around 130 ish 135
sorry can you tell me what it is monthly
it'll help me not have to do as much
mental calculation yeah yeah so uh
monthly after tax yeah we basically
bring in roughly nine thousand dollars
okay so yeah that's going to be almost
half
more than yeah I'm sorry wow so when I
was 20 25 I was like okay it's kind of
close and then obviously I thought it
was new when it was 15 years I was like
okay I'm not even close now so because
my rent's so high I'm like do I carry on
renting and put on like because it might
take me another five years to save up so
the 750 000 home that you're the home
that you're looking at that costs 750
000.
what are you assuming that you'll put
down on that the 150 that you have saved
the 100 the 150 uh can you not just find
a less expensive home is there is that
just Vancouver is pretty rough yeah
there's just not nothing in that area
so yeah so if I move out of the city uh
which it probably isn't really an option
right now just because of jobs
um but if I did move out the city I
could knock that down to like 600s but
even then it would
like I would be moving into something
that's not a nice basically I locked in
my rent since it has a rental
um kind of you can only put it up so
much each year so I locked in my rent
like three years ago during the pandemic
so my 3 000 what I get now is a two
bedroom
um kind of
big Garden like way nicer than what I
would be able to afford I'd be moving in
order so there's a piece of this 600 in
this area the one bedroom essentially
there's a piece of this that is
um a real a real issue and a real
struggle right because you have a family
there's a certain amount of space that
um you do need in order for it to be
worth it to purchase your home right now
but then there's also a piece of it
that's like here's what we would like to
have
also right and I've heard you say it's
not as nice as right it's not as nice as
this we don't want to live in this area
versus it's gonna be a long way and I
you know I always remind people and John
feel free to jump in because I think
you've purchased more real estate than I
have I know you have um I always have to
remind people that real estate's a
ladder and when you get in a lot of
times we want to get in where we want to
be
but that's not the same as getting in at
reality does that make sense like I'll
be honest the first house Sam and I
wanted to purchase I want there were a
lot of things that I wanted and some
things that also you know the market was
kind of demanding as well but you have
to look at that and go okay but yeah but
what can I afford so and where can I
afford it math doesn't have feelings
so here's my promise to you Carl
let's say you went down today you got
off the phone with us you told your wife
I'm buying us a house
and you went down to a local bank and
you would find a lender especially if
you said I have a hundred thousand
dollars but yeah you'd find a lender
and you took out a 30-year mortgage or
25-year Mortgage in Canada
and your payment was half was half of
your take home
yeah and your wife gets pregnant
your wife gets laid off
you get promoted and they say you have
to move right away
what I'm telling you with I promise you
we've done this so long
you would be signing up for what looks
like a dream and it would be a nightmare
down the road or I had an incredible
house that I bought here in in the woods
outside of Nashville Tennessee and I had
to fully inspect it and it was fantastic
and in the last three years I've
replaced the roof and an air conditioner
and some sidewalk stuff and the back
deck and on and on and if you have half
of your income
going to just the bare minimum on a 25
you've changed yourself to a bank for 25
years you change your whole family to a
bank for 25 years
there is no room for life to happen and
you and I both know life happens right
it won't be enjoyable at that point and
so where that where that comes into play
you and your wife start getting short
with each other you don't know why you
start sleeping a little bit less and a
little bit less and stay a little more
time on your phone a little more time in
front of Netflix or whatever you're
watching up in Vancouver
and you find yourself slowly
um caving in on yourself or as the great
writer said you start slowly delving
into your quiet life of desperation all
because you change yourself to something
you could not carry
and so if you said it's gonna take me
five more years I'd say great that's
when you can afford it and so it's not a
matter of I could get it now but you're
right you could get it now a bank will
give you something because they're going
to bundle that loan and sell it to
somebody else and they don't own this
they have no skin in the back side of
this of this game
you though have to pay it and so what
we're saying is yeah rent man make peace
with renting this is where we happen to
be here yeah it's not forever it's five
years or three years or so what if it
takes me 10 years that's the question
because I'm pregnant it won't still my
life is pregnant so my our income is
going to go down I'll say our ability to
save is definitely going to go down oh
then then you have to have hard
conversations about so we have this a
lot somebody calls and says I'm a I'm a
an editor for a magazine in Manhattan
it's been my dream to live in Manhattan
I'm not leaving
but I make twenty eight thousand dollars
a year
and that's when I tell you math doesn't
have feelings and so that's when you
have to have hard conversations that my
wife and I have had that Jade and her
husband have had about where are we
going to actually live I have family
that lived in Los Angeles and they lived
there for a number of years they loved
their careers but they realized they
would never be able to own a home in Los
Angeles making the money that they make
in their career and they had to decide
hey what do we value most do we value
our career most do we value the city
that we live in most or do we value the
idea of having a home with a yard and a
fence and and they decide hey we value
being able to buy a home and so they
move to Atlanta outside of Atlanta
Georgia where they were able to get
something that they could afford and
they made that hard choice and it's been
worth it for them our culture tells us
that that choice that we have to make is
our government's fault is our bank's
fault is our College's fault it's not
you got to make choices for your family
hard ones
but don't buy something you can't afford
we love you more than that we'll be
right back
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsay we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five listen
I have a brand new book coming out
called building a non-anxious life
if you pre-order today you'll get 75
bucks and free bonus items we are
bribing you to buy the book of early
because it helps out with a number of
different metrics and more importantly
the book will be in your mailbox on or
before October 3rd and you'll be ready
to read it and it comes with a free
audiobook all those things
nearly half of the US population reports
that their lives are affected by burnout
anxiety stress whatever you want to call
it I dumped it all in the same bucket
it's everywhere
but you've heard me say this a million
times on the show I'm gonna say it a
million more times anxiety is not the
problem it's just your body trying to
get your attention that the life you are
living is not safe and I don't mean safe
like somebody's coming at you with a
hatchet although that might be the case
but you have changed yourself to
somebody who is making your life unsafe
you are living in a in a toxic
environment you were running and running
and running you and your family into the
ground and if you're driving down the
road you know exactly I'm talking about
right now or if you're sitting at home
listening to this as a podcast you know
exactly what I'm talking about right now
and so this book is a is a plan this is
not me throwing a bunch of theories at
you with me and my nerd friends this is
an actual plan that you sit down with
your family you sit down with your
friends and you say this all ends today
very similar to Total Money Makeover was
like let's sit down and change our money
this is let's sit down and change how
our home feels and how our home operates
let's change everything from the floor
to the ceiling and that's what this book
is if you go to ramseysolutions.com
right now it's 20 bucks and you'll get a
bunch of free stuff like I said and pick
it up and it'll be delivered to you on
or before the release date
um thank you so much over like Jade
we're setting records in the building
it's kind of humbling it's pretty cool
um and uh it's fun to kind of talk trash
with Dave but um
ramsesolutions.com to pick it up I'm
really really grateful
let's run out to Pensacola Florida and
talk to the Great and Powerful Renee
what's up Renee
hey
how are you great
58 years old and have no retirement what
do I do oh girl is it just you we're
just gonna jump in the deep end of the
pool thanks Renee I'm not mad at it
let's let's go through the facts
yeah it is just me okay it's just you
what sort of debt do you have do you
have debt
I do have that so right now I have uh 61
000 in credit card debt and then I have
a car
um thirty three thousand dollars I own
that 11 000 to the IRS that I make
payments on and then of course I have a
9 300 uh student loan that'll be kicking
up again here shortly I am on baby step
two so I'm in my snowball that's where
I'm at
um how'd this happen can you tell me a
little bit about what got you here sure
yeah yeah I can tell you that I went
through a um I was a stay-at-home
homeschool mom for several years and
went through a horrific divorce and
because I was a volunteer firefighter
EMT I went and got a job as a
firefighter EMT and to had two hundred
thousand dollars worth of debt I was
responsible for in the divorce and
started making 9.50 an hour and I had
three children relying on me so I've
gone through the years
um you know went from a firefighter to
working into technology
raising the kids getting them one
through college one marriage and I'm
kind of settled in to my own place here
I've owned two homes so I've kind of
moved up when I went to work for the
company I work for now and started at
the bottom I've worked my way up
um and I'm making good what are you
making what are you making now
right now I'm making between
130 to 140 a year with bonus very good
and I heard you say that you had two
homes is that you working selling one
and buying another or you currently have
two homes
so I I have one home now I did buy one
um in Colorado and sold that and moved
home to Florida okay and the home that
you have now in Florida would you know
what do you owe on it tell me more about
that oh yeah yeah so I just bought this
home
um just a little under two years ago so
I owe 318 on this home uh-huh
and what's it worth
um it's worth right now market value is
between 350 380 is what they're saying
okay now sorry I'm about to ask you just
rapid fire questions because I want to
make sure I understand everything
um can you tell me your monthly
take-home pay after taxes
yeah you bet it's 10 standby
um it is
784 good and can you tell me what your
mortgage payment is that comes out every
month yeah my yep my mortgage payment is
uh two thousand seventy two dollars
okay
um 2072. all right it's very close
um
all right you gotta Miss but you've got
a decent sized shovel actually you've
got a pretty good size shovel you got
about 125 000 of debt okay
um of course you know baby step two
we're paying off everything except the
mortgage
um you're making about 130 140
it's just you now kids are moved on
they're in college
what graduated yeah they're they're way
into life so what would it just look
like you living on
half of what you earn you're living on
beans and rice like Dave would say beans
and rice rice and beans living on
nothing and you're spending the next two
years paying off 125 000 a debt the next
two and a half years getting after it
I mean that's really what it is
yeah so that's my plan right is to be
debt free by 2026
um but there's a couple other things
that I'm looking at right so I have this
career it's it's a career
um but what I really want to do is
change careers so I'm looking at getting
and getting my real estate associate
license
um I've already taken the class I'm
getting ready to go uh take the test
um to get my state license and then I
wanted to kind of continue my career do
real estate part-time until after two
years where I can get my broker license
and then move into property management
and actually be free to kind of move out
of the corporate career and into a
different career I don't think there's
anything wrong with that but in this
case you need to maintain
your income or higher while you do all
of that right that's that would be my
only caveat to that I mean I'm not mad
at any of that as long as you're
maintaining your income and higher as
you're making that transition
um and then of course the quick I mean
here's the thing the quicker we get out
of baby step two the quicker we're
getting that emergency fund the quicker
we can start investing for the future
because here's the thing getting out of
debt that's just thing one right you've
got a whole future ahead of you you're
going to be working for a while because
I want you to retire with paid for home
right and once you get this debt cleared
you might have to take a look at that
I'm just going to be honest you might
have to take an honest look at that
situation I don't really know
um in in Florida it would be a condo it
would be something that was less
expensive than that to get you to still
have ownership but to have a less you
know less amount of money tied up
to where you can also start investing
more you're gonna have to at some point
have a little bit more of an honest
conversation but it's all going to
depend on how quickly you get this debt
cleared so Renee let me let me say this
um
my guess is you spent a long time
towards the end of your marriage you
spent a long time after your marriage
cleaning up messes running around doing
all this stuff and you had this one day
this one day this is going to one day
this is going to one day this is going
to
have that house one name and do whatever
the crap I want to do because I'm sick
of
paying off somebody else's debt sick of
raising these kids by myself on and on
and on
and I'm saying this because I love you
Renee you are 58 and you're broke
you make an incredible salary and you
owe a hundred and twenty five thousand
dollars and you went and bought a 350 to
400 000 home
and I want more than anything I want you
to have that big home with a pool and a
in a Seaside view I want all that for
you
but it might be that you can just afford
a condo and I'd much rather you be 65 or
and have a paid for a condo and then
you're thinking about doing real estate
on the side when you want because you
wrote out a six-figure job for 15 years
even though you didn't love it I know
you want these other things but I don't
want you to lose sight of reality math
does not care about your feelings and I
hate to say that but it doesn't
we want this for you get out of debt as
soon as you possibly can by the way sell
that car get something cheaper and put
that IRS debt first those are action
items
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five I'm
John deloney joined by Jade warshaw
listen if you are totally frustrated bye
like Jade and I were talking in an
earlier segment
the trillions of dollars we owe in
student loans and credit card or the way
Congress spends money or the way your
neighbors or whatever whatever
a no cost way costs nothing that you can
help everybody in your community out and
Beyond is to just like or um subscribe
to the show if you're listening to if
you're watching this on YouTube just hit
the Subscribe button
um whatever device you are leave a five
star review click and like whatever
whatever the thing is on your device
because the more people that do that it
kicks up in the algorithms and it puts
it in front of people who are Googling
in the middle of the night I can't
breathe how do I pay out this debt or
what do I do about student loans or my
credit card's out of control and the
more you just like the show it kicks it
up more in the algorithms and it puts
the show in front of people who are
hurting who need it and this is the way
we're going to spread this message we
are not going to put the Ramsay name on
on football stadiums we're going to
continue to be Grassroots and put it up
in front of hurting people in the middle
of the night on their computer screens
or in their podcast feed and that's how
we're going to change the world so just
take a second didn't cost anything and
it's a way to help change everything for
our communities thank you so so much for
those of you who are doing that let's
run out to Dallas Texas and talk to
Nicholas what's up Great and Powerful
Nicholas
hey what's up John how are you doing
doing great man how are you
I'm doing great doing great glad to talk
to you guys you too man what's up
yeah hey um I've had a quick question
um basically all I wanted to know was if
I should pay more towards my mortgage or
if I should
um hold off on that and uh stay for my
second baby me and my wife's second baby
ooh congrats on the second baby that's
cool so I'm just making the assumption
that uh you have three to six months
saved I'm making the assumption that
you are investing 15 during this process
you're so much better than me I was
making the assumption that
um your wife said now that baby two is
coming we're getting a house
January of this year and yes I'm out of
debt and saving 15 and
um forgot the other one uh three six
months expenses yeah do you have three
months or six months
yes oh three months three months okay
um
what I would do is yeah I'd probably
pull back and just save up a pile of
cash keep a bunch of money there for
sure make sure you have enough to cover
your deductible because you're at least
gonna hit that with this baby and then
yeah just go ahead and pile it up when
baby gets here and the baby is healthy
and beautiful and all those warm and
snuggly cuddly things that babies are
you can just take that big chunk of
money and throw it at the mortgage and
uh that's gonna feel pretty great I
think that's what I do that's that's a
pretty easy thing you don't lose either
way no nothing lost matter of fact you
just get a lot of Peace it's always
peaceful knowing that you're sitting on
a big chunk of money you know
right yeah and uh the the main reason I
was asking was because
um even if we pay the extra three
hundred dollars we a lot of the money
that we're gonna save we won't need
immediately after the baby is born you
know just like the hospital bills is
Gonna Come a little while after the the
baby is born and all that so I thought
maybe we could just say that what we
needed
um for whenever the baby's actually here
you know I would actually flip that
around dude and I'd just sit down with
the hospital
and I would say can I get a statement on
on a statement up front
and right okay almost all of them will
give you a statement up front and you
can ask for the cash payout and I think
on one of my kids we did the cash payout
because it was cheaper to do that than
our deductible was going to be on our
insurance plan hmm that's interesting
really okay so walking in could be they
get stiffed a lot so if you walk in and
say if I write you a check for this
birth assuming that you know the baby
doesn't end up in in some sort of NICU
or something like that right
um right but just a traditional
um you know delivery and mothercare and
Aftercare and all that what's the check
wait I just learned something I'll give
you a number I didn't know you could do
that they love having a check yeah okay
so I always try that I would not here's
what I want to avoid I don't want to
just putter along and wait for these
bills to just trickle into our house
yeah and you don't want to have to use
your emergency fund for this because
technically it's not an emergency you
know it's coming so save up your own
cash I love John's idea anything that's
going to get this done cheaper and with
less of a unknown it's the
intentionality yeah that's right I like
that yeah yeah so good for you man
congratulations we'll be cheering you on
uh when this baby's born healthy and
beautiful wonderful soon to say uh a
photo and um we'll see if we can post it
up there we're proud of you brother
we're proud of you all right let's go
out to Green Bay where Aaron Rodgers
just left and talked to Bailey what's up
Bailey
how are you
good thanks for taking my call of course
what's up so
um my husband and I we've been dead pre
for about three years and we paid off
our student loans shortly before coven
uh but when the Biden student loan
relief refund came out we thought well
maybe we'll apply for the ten thousand
dollar refund and then if it comes
through we'll cash the check if it
doesn't fall through we'll just tear the
check up
so we have a check for ten thousand
dollars that we never cashed and we do
not plan to yeah and uh now save it for
the next toilet paper shortage
yeah right
well now the loan provider that the
student loans were originally with they
said that we owe ten thousand dollars
regardless of if we cash the check or
not well yeah because you got a refund
on your payments
even though we never cashed it yeah you
got the refund on your pay it's
basically let's It's All Therapy to make
it simple let's say your loan was ten
thousand dollars and you paid it off and
then Biden said oh we're gonna give you
forgiveness so you went and said hey I
want my money back because Biden's about
to clear this so they gave you ten
thousand dollars back you held on to it
waiting for Biden to clear the
Forgiveness he didn't so unless you want
to owe ten thousand dollars you need to
give them back their check does that
make sense or did I miss something on
what you were saying well does that mean
that we should cash the check and then
just take the cash and put it right back
into the loan yeah I mean what it sounds
like yeah they wrote the check to you so
you need to you know liquefy that money
and then digitize that money and give
them their payment online my guess is
there is a separate wing of this
whatever chaos is in there that sends
out the refund checks and once that
refund checked goes out it goes on a
balance sheet and gets sent to another
department and there's another
department just going down saying ten
thousand ten thousand ten thousand and
you're probably one of about six people
out of 40 million people that didn't
cash that and go buy a car with it
and so you may end up as silly as this
is you may end up catching this check to
turn on and write them a check right
back well let me ask you this the check
get in the car right now go to the bank
you put it you know I think you can do
it online now but cash that check
because this is what I don't trust
because student loan look I don't trust
them because if that check expires
they're gonna be like well you cash the
check we don't have a record of it
you will owe ten thousand dollars and
you won't have the money to pay it so to
today please so the wild the last the
last thing I
I have enough hesitancy in my voice
because I'm not looking at this check
and I haven't heard of this problem I
may call the servicer back who is
telling you this and say and you tell
them I'm holding a paper check that you
tell me I owe you
so I'm about to go to this to the bank
cash this put in my account and write
you a ten thousand dollar check is that
correct
and they will probably just say you owe
us ten thousand dollars
like a like a computerized program but I
would check with him to make sure or ask
him is there two different departments
here because I never cashed this check
my guess is they just have a record that
you were written a check and they want
their money back they don't have the
deposits record that's my guess
earlier and they did basically say that
like well you're liable for it whether
you cash it or not that's right that's
well yeah because for them they just saw
the money go out you said you wanted
forgiveness when you checked the box and
the rest was it truly was on you to
either hold on to that money or spend it
like so many other people did so good on
you for not spending the money but now
it's time to get down to the bank get
that money and give it back to your
student loan service provider so you can
be free once and for all and I'm gonna
applaud Washington for spending our tax
dollars wisely once again way to go guys
foreign
[Music]
home buying Market but there's a way you
can get an edge Churchill Mortgage works
with you to understand your budget and
your goals and the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge offers you fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus Churchill has bumped up their
seller guarantee to ten thousand dollars
giving your offer the best chance of
being accepted and helping you win in
today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsay show listen to this
smart conference is a weekend event with
Dave Rachel me jade George camel Ken
Coleman in Chicago Illinois on September
15th and 16th it's gonna be a party
dedicated weekend to be focused and
dialed in on achieving your goals in
money emotional health mental health
career and relationships
school has started and you already all
of your good intentions are already out
the window and it has turned into a
blender without a top on
this is a great weekend to go and
control alt delete and reset and not
just emotionally not just rah-rah but
with some actual plans to go out and
change your life it's a day and a half
event packed with motivation information
and inspiration that's a lot of Asians
that's uh Ken Coleman that is kid
Coleman all day smart conference weekend
is our biggest event of the Year tickets
start at 99 bucks and there's a limited
limited ticket upgrades available that
include meet and greets go to
ramseysolutions.com events to get your
tickets ramseysolutions.com events all
of us in one place at the same time it
is a blast it's a blast all right let's
run out to Oklahoma City or as Texans
call it Southern Canada and talk to Pam
what's up Pam
[Music]
Pam I almost broke into my Oklahoma
weather
what's up
oh not much I just have a quick question
that my husband and I are kind of
disagreeing about your input we will
solve this for your marriage bring it
okay thanks okay so last year we bought
a new truck and we are we are debt free
um including two homes and all of our
cars for this one and hold on you're
like I'm in in I am a super fast runner
except I'm very slow
I am debt free except I'm not debt free
and I own a truck how much do you owe on
this truck
that's what bothers me is because I
can't say that now because I have this
truck but here's the deal it's free
interest zero percent interest
yes so my question is is do we go ahead
and just pay it off and then I can
actually say I'm debt free or do we
continue it until it pays off which
would be about another two years
how much is
the loan is it was initially like 40
something thousand but now it's twenty
six thousand twenty six help me with
this Pam help me with this you'll have
two paid for homes
yeah how much money do you have saved
hold on before that how could you all do
this to yourselves you all made a
promise and a commitment to yourselves
that we're gonna be different live a
different way
what happened right
well you know how those viewerships talk
to you and say hey we can do this no not
Jade and I we know that we just leave
why didn't you wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait
um that's hey that's the same thing like
how did you cheat on her and it's like
well you know how them women talk to you
no I'm just you look look look look you
walked into the dealership I know they
didn't come get you at your house okay
you walked in without the cash if you
walk into the dealership without a cat
without the cash and you're like I'm
just gonna look around they're gonna
sell you okay these look I tell people
all the time man willpower s willpower
in some ways is for punks because if the
cookies are sitting on the desk you're
gonna eat I don't eat one I'm gonna eat
a bunch of them exactly you know what
I'm saying and that's what happened to
you Pam
yeah I know I know so here's the deal
he's saying you know why not why tie up
the money that's in the bank let it
continue to draw interest it's already
tied up that's a it's a straw man's it's
you have you have you're either going to
be tied up to a bank or you're going to
be tied up to a car dealership you're
already tied
that's not the that is a that's a false
that's a false truth
I know you got some money laying around
Pam how much money do you have laying
around
uh you mean liquid yeah like in your
savings anything that's not retirement
money
okay
um about 450 000. good God on a stick
with a pony what are you talking about
in cash I thought you were gonna say
like well you know we're really
struggling
y'all are millionaires to to quote Neil
Young
today yeah okay pay it up today Pam
listen tell your husband that hey he
needs to get a better calculator
B that y'all made a commitment that
y'all were gonna be debt-free
millionaires and that you're just
playing with fire and playing with fire
and you're playing with fire and here's
here's all seriousness this is the
moment when everything is perfect and
somebody gets sick
this is the moment when everything
happens and somebody loses their job or
the market goes down and you're holding
this thing that was no big deal it's
something that's a big deal yeah and
you're making it a big deal because
you know it's got no interest here we
can get four percent in our high yield
savings account
there's a four percent sleep tax on you
I can hear it
right what what do you mean I mean it's
costing you your your sleep at night the
paltry amount of money you're gonna make
over two years in a high yield savings
account on twenty six thousand dollars
is almost nothing and it's costing you
way more every moment you wake up and
the first thing you think is I can't
believe we went back into debt well yeah
because yeah yeah you guys said you were
going to live one way you chose not to
and the thing is you weren't even backed
into a corner no it was just uh you got
not played by a car dealer yeah and
you've got the money hey here's what I
want you to walk away from this you guys
need to be confident in your choices and
what you know to do you guys are debt
free you've got homes paid for homes
paid for cars 450 000 in liquid cash you
no one tells you guys what to do all
right you tell them what you're gonna do
and in this case there you go you know
what I'm saying in this case you're
going to go down there you're going to
pay this off I am going to correct
myself and say Neil Diamond instead of
Neil Young and you are going to be debt
free by the end of this call you're
gonna get off here you're gonna call
them paid off and you're going to feel
so good because you're going to stand
your ground and you're never going back
into debt again right yeah I think
you're right I think you're right yeah
love that are you gonna really do this
fam
yeah no I really will trust me I'll get
off this phone and I will tell him what
you said and then we will go pay it off
let's do it if you want to have some fun
just
um do the quick calculation real quick
four percent on twenty six thousand
dollars over 24 months it's and put that
number down in front of him and tell him
a wife with peace in her heart is worth
more than this dollar amount I know that
yeah the wife that will love you and not
wake up every day wanting to hit you
with the exact truck that you took a
loan out on like is worth more than this
dollar amount
and it just make it make it very very
real
yeah that's true that sounds good I
think I'll do that and let's like for
everybody listening who's kind of
rolling their eyes
mathematically your husband's right it's
free money that math makes sense and if
this was a show about math it would be a
14 second show this is a show about
freedom
mm-hmm and we're not talking about math
he made a good math move you mean I can
borrow money for the X number of years
for free for nothing and I can make a
little bit of pocket change over here
and a high yield savings account on the
side great that's a good math problem
but it doesn't take into account the
wife that is saying hey this is not Who
We Are
this is this is not who we say we're
going to be we were going to be a couple
who is free no like I love that we say
that Jade nobody tells Pam and Company
what to do nobody
except for you know how them car dealers
are
a word to the wise I just you know I you
can't put yourself in the situation to
be tempted like that you go to the car
dealership just to look around I'm just
browsing they're trained they're trained
karate experts they will karate you I
mean it's like it's like going to sit in
the bar when you said you're not gonna
drink right you can't put yourself in
these situations and then be like I'm
gonna willpower my way out like you're
just why it's too whenever I have one of
my like no candy promises to myself I
can't walk down the aisle don't do it
because I'm not trustworthy in those
moments when it comes to Candy so yes
Pam take the Temptation with you um you
win the argument Pam one husband zero
but remember this too if you win and he
loses you both lose so make this
decision together it's another hour of
the books here on the Ramsey Show we're
so grateful that you have been with us
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions is the Ramsey
show where we help people build wealth
do work that is Meaningful that they
love and to improve and develop
relationships I'm John deloney joined by
Jade warshaw and we are taking your
calls on money and marriage life work
all of it triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five give us a buzz
and we will we may not know the answer
but we will sit with you and figure it
out let's go out to Austin Texas and
talk to Kendra in the 512. what's up
Kendra
hey everyone what you're hanging out
what's up guys we're just hanging out
too how can we help
so 15 years ago my husband and I go to
get married and he is very adamant he
does not want to combine funds
absolutely not we're going to sell
everything 50 50 from our separate
accounts
so okay great now 15 years later I now
make three times his income I've worked
really hard to get myself out of debt
and now he wants to combine fun
and I'm really struggling with accepting
that after I've put in all the hard work
and time wow to say okay
all right can I how honest can I be with
you
as honest as you want
this is not the main issue in your
marriage and you know that and your
marriage is on real thin ice true or
false yeah true true very true this is a
periphery issue that's way outside
the the
um contempt with which you're talking
about your husband tells me there's way
bigger issues going on here Fair
yeah yeah money will take care of itself
joining finances is something we like I
I I can't wrap my head around making a
kid and not trusting my spouse like
making a human with my wife but not
trusting her enough to share accounts I
can't wrap my head around that so we do
tell people man if you want to be
unified join accounts this isn't that
situation yet that kind of stuff often
takes care of itself not always but
often you guys got bigger fish tell me
what's going on man
I honestly don't know I think
um I just kept trying to like we had
goals and I kept trying to reach them
and
no it felt really alone I would say
it's always been almost a roommate
we just live
that's the single most that's the single
most used word I hear behind closed
doors sitting with couples
we're roommates
or they laugh and try to chuckle the
tears away and say like we're Michael
Scott and Jim when we're co-managers of
our house right but that's about it sure
there's no intimacy there's no we're not
both working towards this goal out there
that we're going to go get it is I'm
gonna do my stuff I'll get my report
turned in on time he didn't do his
report on time and now I got to do his
his work that is I mean that is a recipe
for resentment in a relationship to end
up in Ash
if it's not there already
yeah and this is the moment when
somebody at work is hilarious
and they text you a meme and you text
back and then they text back and then
you text back and then a few days later
you're turning your phone over when your
husband walks in the room or vice versa
that's this moment right now if it's not
already Fair
sure it's not there I know I get what
you're saying yeah but maybe right so um
15 years ago I'm just curious 15 years
ago did you want to combine money and it
was just him that was like no or were
you like I'm good with being separate no
um I wanted to but at the same time
um I came from nothing at the time I was
in school I had a car payment because I
was an idiot at 18 bought a brand new
car
um so I was like you know what I totally
get it I'll I'll pay my half
um I'm responsible for myself fine
um so is he is he just a deadbeat why do
you resent him so much okay let me ask
this you don't like him why
I I don't know is he controlling him I
know you love him I know I don't
question that judgmental you don't like
um
I think he doesn't understand he was
born more privileged which is great but
he does he discounts the hard work that
everybody else has to put in and so now
that I'm somewhere he's not it's oh well
now this is part mine and we've earned
it and it's like well no you didn't come
to school with me you didn't take care
of the house while I was gone I did all
of this yeah y'all are in a mess man um
you all need to make an appointment with
the marriage counselor by the end of
next week
okay and I need you to be honest and
strong and bold as strong as you are
presenting to us right now you need to
be that strong in a therapy session and
say those words out loud that you just
said here that's right
otherwise that's just gonna fester and I
mean it already has we hear it
you don't like him you think he is a
scam he is like a mooch off of you and
you think over the last 15 years you've
worked harder than him and his life has
been easier than yours and he just
doesn't understand how hard work is that
might be a hundred percent true and it
might not be and the reality is it
doesn't matter because you believe it
and you cannot have intimacy if you are
one-upping or one Downing your spouse
all the time and he might be doing the
exact same thing with you and maybe he
is a total mooch just
feed up Netflix on you know tall boy in
his hand waiting on Mama to bring home
the paycheck and suddenly this is all
ours maybe that's him I think it was in
the beginning he viewed himself up here
and she needed to reach that standard
right yeah and then when she blew
pasture whatever standard he created and
she accepted then it's like oh well wait
a minute
now I get to now now it's enough and now
I want to be part of it and now she's
it's almost like now you're doing the
same thing he did in the beginning
that's the table's turned
yeah and I don't want that I really
genuinely am trying to live for a more
Godly relationship a Godly marriage but
I just can't get over the frustration
and goodness so even in the conversation
now it's not I want us to be one I want
us to enjoy all of this together and
work hard to you know get better it's
well now you make more than me so I
don't have to worry about you spending
all of my money well that's not trust
that's not a marriage that's not a
marriage that's not even a good friend
yeah I guess I have a good buddy there's
remember back in like high school
there's always that one guy that's like
no bro you owe me 436 because I got the
Wendy's combo last time they just that
annoying guy and then there's also that
other buddy that's like no dude I got it
no I got it I got it and the fist fights
were almost who was gonna pay not he
wasn't like that's mirror yeah that's
marriage
um
so
the great Esther perel talks about gave
a very beautiful elegant picture that I
want you to hold tight okay here's the
picture it was talking she was talking
about a couple that had um one of them
had cheated on the other one
and she said the most damaging thing is
couples all whenever something like that
happens where there's a fracture in the
relationship they always want to go back
to what was remember when right
and she gave us a very beautiful picture
she says you could not go on September
12th the day after the Twin Towers fell
and sweep up all the glass and steel and
wood and all of that mess and use those
same materials and rebuild the towers
they fell they fell you have two choices
you let him sit and let nature take it
back over or you get some professionals
in there you excavate it you create
something new so I want to tell you the
relationship that y'all have had is over
your choice now is do we walk away or do
we work together and do whatever it
takes to build something new get in with
a marriage therapist ASAP stay on the
line and hook you up with better help
that will help you all get in I'll give
you three free months to just get
started call somebody today your
marriage is in crisis we'll be right
back
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back this is the Ramsey Show I'm
John deloney joined by Jade warshaw
we're taking your calls on money and
life triple eight eight two five five
two two five let's go to Rachel in
Kansas City what is up Rachel
hello can you hear me
hey
um so I'm 31 and my husband's 29 and we
have a 10 month old and we're praying
for more and we have some assets and we
wanted to know if we should just update
our will yes trust assets we have some
assets
very okay much better
sorry yes assets assets excellent okay
okay go ahead update our will okay or if
we should go with a trust and if we do a
trust what kind and what's like a
reasonable amount to pay a lawyer and we
just want to set up our baby for success
and be a blessing not a burden to
um her Guardians
yeah I think that you've probably both a
will is good to just
um make sure that you have that initial
setting there but whenever you're
dealing with a child uh I would involve
a trust because let's just say you've
got you know a hundred thousand dollars
in Investments and you've got a home and
God forbid something were to happen to
you and your husband you wouldn't want
an 18 year old to get a bunch of money
all at once right plus Life Insurance
Plus life insurance and so with the
trust it's a living document so it's it
grows with your family it grows with
your kids and so with the trust you
could say hey
here's how we want to space that out we
want them to get this at age 18 we want
them to get this and you can
differentiate all of that whereas a will
it's kind of just all at once it happens
one time and that's it you go through
probate that's it and so that's I would
suggest that I'd suggest getting with a
lawyer it's going to be kind of
expensive but nothing that you can't
handle if you plan for it yeah I don't
think you have a do you have how much
you think that that should cost because
we've talked with one and then we're
like eh we'll put on the back burner but
now I feel like it's a little bit more
of something the last time I talked to
somebody about a trust was about 2 500
bucks but it was for a specific real
estate transaction so I don't know if
that's making your entire will
um I was working at a law school at the
time so I had a colleague that hooked me
up in a pretty dramatic fashion so
um that's like a super super lucky there
but when I talked to with with Sam and I
and ours it was about double that about
around five thousand
um and I recently spoke to someone who
theirs was even more than that so I
think it just depends on
what's going on in your situation
everything that's going to go into the
trust all of that sort of thing so I
would just get with a a lawyer and uh
start walking through that process and
price it out I mean you're interviewing
these people so you don't have to go
with the first person that raises their
hand
but in the meantime Rachel um it's super
important
um make sure you have a will of some
sort and we we partner with Mama Bear
Wills
um and we'll put a link in the show
notes there for Mama Bear Wills
um but get something in writing which is
super important that's the first step
do you guys have any sort of suggestions
on what you do for disbursements the
estate would be about two and a half
million
um and so we'd want to step that through
in a way that would be responsible yeah
you know Dave always says this and I
agree
um you stipulate it in a way that
they're living their life
uh according to guidelines that you have
set and talked with them about and so
that they understand so uh you want to
make sure you know whatever whatever
your Clause is hey if you're gonna get
this money you can't be doing drugs you
can't be uh living out here just wilding
out these are the things that are going
to have to be in place for you to get
this money and by the way here's how
it's dispersed and the big key thing
here is
once your baby is old enough for you to
talk to them about these things and
they're mature enough to handle it you
need to be talking to them about it
saying hey here's what happens here's
what you'll get here's what the
inheritance is and here's what this
means and so as long as you're having
very clear communication about that as
soon as they're old enough to understand
and it not be you know there's there's a
maturity here you're not talking to them
about this at eight years old okay but
that part's in place and you know the
way my husband and I have it anybody
who's part of that they know and they
know what their job is and they know
what the situation is so as much
conversation as you can have you know
we're not talking about hundreds of
millions of dollars here so I think that
there's just an aspect of okay like an
18 year old yeah you're not giving them
2.5 million dollars you know I'd
probably
I I don't want to tell you what to do
because this is your life but I would be
thinking okay they're Pro if I was gone
and they're 18 they're probably going to
want need money for college they're
going to need money for a new car
they're gonna you know on and on I'm
gonna want to give them money when I
think it's time for their first down
payment on their home and then in their
40s I'd love to help them out in this
way so I'm thinking about those
milestones in their life and that's how
that money would be dispersed I'm
thinking about when they might have
children I'm thinking about that so
really just I mean it's up to you and
your husband how you decide this but um
and here's how we did it and I want to
leave some of our stuff is it's private
but I assigned a trustee who's somebody
that
um I trust with my life
and he knows me very well and so um and
my wife very well obviously and so he is
the custodian of this trust and so if
something goes sideways then he will be
responsible for making sure tuition is
paid because I spent my career working
with 18 year olds and I'm not giving an
18 year old no matter how great and
wonderful they are I'm not going to give
an 18 year old 100 000 so they're gonna
he's gonna make sure the tuition is paid
and he's going to make sure that there's
a drivable car and there's a difference
between what he would say is drivable
and what an 18 year old with a hundred
thousand dollars would say it's drivable
right and ultimately it's released in
that way until my kids are reached age X
when we'll start to release some of this
to him but the bigger deal for me was
finding somebody that I trust in my
absence and I remember a conversation
with my wife and again when you're
talking at Dave's money when you're
talking hundreds of millions of dollars
we're in a totally different
conversation when you're talking our
money like we have life insurance and a
house and a couple of cars and you know
a neat guitar that we like something
like that
um I said to you know who would ever
take our kids when they're minors um I
want to make sure that we got in writing
so they can't do X Y and Z and my wife
said if we don't trust them that much
then why in the world have we named them
as are the new parents of our kids and I
thought you know what I'm not going to
spend my life trying to legislate life
from the grave I'm gonna do I'm going to
make as good a choice as I can I am
going to put it out there and give
people wisdom I'm going to get somebody
I trust and then I'm gonna have full
peace I think it's it's trying to
control every single solitary variable
right now on the front end here
um that you're gonna make yourself nuts
does that make sense
yeah it does we just we've never had a
baby before and we just want to make
sure that
she's in a good spot I guess and any
other kids and it's not a burden that's
that's the thing that we really don't
want to be uh the people that are
friends that agreed to be grandparents
we just don't want this to be something
that makes their life even harder with
accepting so flip that right flip that
around flip that around
they said yes
we would be honored to carry on your
legacy and raise your child if something
God forbid were to happen to you
don't take away their
um
their heart
by trying to lighten that load
they're someone who loves you and
there's your friends and they said no
we'll carry this and so if you then go
okay but I'm gonna try to make it as
light as possible no no they said we're
in
and so obviously do your part
do your part
just for whatever it's worth having sat
with people parents who lost their kids
or sat with kids who lost their parents
there is no way to prepare you think
there is psychologically and mentally
it's a burden it's powerful it's awful
which is why we have a trust set up
where at least we don't have to worry
about food and shelter and education
right so that we have the privilege of
just being really really sad and
grieving and going through all that
process and so don't spend all of your
energy trying to light and load on them
do do your due diligence find somebody
you trust and say Here's where you're
going to be the custodian this money
this it needs to go we they need to have
their education taken care of they might
have to buy a bigger van though because
y'all might have three kids by that
point and they have three kids they have
to get another van that's some of that
money's gonna go to that right so let's
sit down and talk to them you trust them
to enough to take your kids and then
let's put some guidelines on there and
then let's take our hands off let's just
don't get too too bananas about every
single very we're gonna make yourself
nuts
okay you're lucky to have great friends
and honestly you're lucky you've
cultivated those friendships over time
and so good for you that's fantastic
of Jade one of the hardest things to do
is thinking about who's gonna take her
kids I'm like not being here without our
kids and that's a hard thing to Think
Through Rachel good on you good parents
millions of people have children and no
will and there is simply no excuse for
that other than cowardice and avoidance
get a will get a will get a will we'll
be right back
thank you
[Music]
squat to Phoenix Arizona and talk to
Brandi Brandy this is the Ramsey show
what's up
hey
um I just was calling because first of
all I wanted to tell you John that um I
have engaged in some pretty destructive
behaviors in our marriage um with money
and I could never figure out why I was
doing it until I started listening to
you
um and so my husband and I have been
able to kind of cut off with credit card
debt um all of our cars are paid off we
don't have any other debt besides that
um I'm so proud of you decided Well
thank you it's awesome
um but he has decided to sell his Jeep
that
um
he loves to pay off this credit card
debt and I just feel really guilty
because I know most of it was me making
just really resentful and dumb choices
yeah
he loves that jeep
he does how much
we love that jeep
um a lot I mean give me an example how
much
a lot a lot more than like kind of a
ridiculous amount kind of like almost
annoying how much he loves his Jeep
no no he's not like a jeeper like he
doesn't like that here's what I'm
getting at yeah yeah here's what I'm
getting at he loves you more
don't take that from him
okay he signed up ride or die with
brandy
and he's he's known for a long time you
were hurting
and probably some of the fights y'all
had were very tactical things about
money and credit card debt and you have
done the hard work
to dig in beneath that what why in the
world am I spending on this am I out of
control here why when I get nervous or
scared or when my mom calls I spin like
crate whatever you did that work
and then he exhaled and went oh thank
God now we got a plan I'm all in
okay and a giant giant Go-Kart with
humongous tires comes way after
the woman I love
okay
guilt is fine guilt is fair that's cool
foreign
it becomes ugly when your guilt becomes
shame and you know the difference
is I did some stupid things with money
shame is I am stupid and I always will
be
okay it's okay to feel guilty you did
some did you do some dumb things with
money
yeah yeah that's cool that's just your
body doing what's supposed to do letting
you know let's not do that again
remember how that felt that's cool
shame is I'm not going to be able to
breathe because as we're cleaning up
other people who love me so much have
agreed to participate in the cleanup
and by the way he signed up for that
when he said I do it's part of it
okay cool um yeah I just was wondering
with it to like
um so we were two income we've gone down
to one income for me to go back to
school
um because we have three kids and anyway
um I just
I know that he would have sold this beep
anyway to make like to provide more for
them while we were on income so every
time things come up where it's like
we're canceling music lessons or
something for my kids I just like feel
so the greatest gift the greatest gift
you can give your kids is a well Mom
okay by a hundred miles
way more important than a violin lesson
or whatever is a mom who has peace
inside her chest
okay
so every time you go to counseling every
time you have to cancel something
because you're back in school every time
you are staying up late and you have to
miss a ball game because you have an
exam the next day
exhale and think
what a gift I'm giving my kids I'm
giving them a peaceful mom a well mother
I'm giving them warmth and laughter in
their home
because when I get out of school it's
going to be gangbusters
not I can't believe I missed this t-ball
game
whatever I promise you of all the t-ball
games they have they're not gonna
remember the one you lost they don't
even remember what they ate for dinner
yesterday they will remember
how mom made him feel
okay it was Mom safe was Mom anxious all
the time was Mom scared all the time or
was Mom
the the one warm place I always knew I
could go to
and that's the work you're doing right
now
all right is that fair
do you believe me
um you don't have to please my kids are
teenagers so I that makes it a little
different but I think it doesn't like
packing can I tell you one more
take each one of them out for breakfast
and tell them
age appropriate I would tell that
differently to my 13 year old than I
would an 18 year old
but Mom's going to a hard season and
you're watching your mom become a
gangster in front of your very eyes
and I'm gonna tell you I have a mom that
had a hard
some hard experiences went back to
school at 42 and you probably heard that
story I went back to school at 42 First
Community College class at 42 and then
she took another one the next year and
another one the next semester
and then she graduated with her PhD at
57.
then she got tenured as a professor at
63 and we all just celebrated her
because she finished her last year at
Oxford in her 70s
she had a whole gangster back half of
her life that started when I was a
teenager
and it was hard she missed games I had
to make dinner on my own sometimes and I
wouldn't trade any of it for the the
watching my mom take a machete and head
out into a field and carve a path and
watching my dad support her all the way
wouldn't trade a second of that
okay okay I've lived I've lived it
you're doing the right thing I'm proud
of you proud of you proud of you proud
of you proud of you it's awesome good
for you yes good for you call anytime we
got you let's go out to uh Mike right
down the street oh we're gonna run out
of time here
you think so
well we're spending it
we've spent it
all right let's run out right down the
street too well now we're now or even
later let's try it let's try it come on
Mike just so just here's some inside
baseball
the way my my when I look at the call
that's coming up I look directly up at
James is right behind the screen so
sometimes I reach over to make a call
and I see James grimsing as though
someone just lit him on fire and that
means no John you're making a terrible
decision with your life
and so I went to take the call from Mike
did he shake his head slowly he looked
at me and was like you're failing the
show
it's all right
so we'll catch him around
um let me Circle back now you and I are
we'll just chop it up so let me let me
ask you this based on that last call
you have two little ones yeah and I only
know by the the literature I don't know
by personal experience what I would call
the industrial mom guilt complex oh man
you can't be home enough you can't work
enough you can't be present enough you
can't be
um domestic enough you can't be making
enough money
the struggle is real okay the struggle
is real I mean I was uh before I came
here to Ramsey I worked from home and it
allotted me a lot more freedom to be
there for the kids when I took this job
I I'm not gonna lie I mean I know I
shouldn't feel guilt about certain
things but I do I missed my little boys
uh what is it uh teddy bears and tea
parties thing at his kindergarten and I
felt terrible you know um will there be
another teddy bear tea party yes there
will I will be at that one you know and
George Campbell invites us to those at
his house all the time
but look I mean I one of the things I
value is cooking meals for my kids I
don't get to cook every night anymore
and that's okay they also at the same
time my son sits out here behind the
glass and he gets to watch his mom
talk and help millions of people and you
know sometimes I have to tell myself
okay like this matters that matters too
all of it matters the good and the bad
it balances itself out and when you
start feeling out of balance and you
start feeling some type of way you do
maybe need to walk in and make some
changes and readjust but it's a constant
Readjustment a constant rebalance you're
constantly telling yourself okay am I
doing enough do I need to change this do
I need to change that that's just that
is being a mom I think the more you can
chop it up into Seasons what's right for
this season let's pray for the next one
we'll try for the next one and
reevaluate revaluate reevaluate it's
hard yeah and when y'all get it right
come tell me and tell me what the secret
sauce I don't know it how to not feel
guilty you'd be a trillionaire this is
the Ramsay show we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
scripture of the day is Philippians 2
3-4
do nothing out of selfish ambition or
vain conceit rather in humility value
others above yourselves not looking to
your own interests but each of you to
the interests of others wow talk about
good word talk about a word for James
the Great and Powerful meatloaf
stop what hey what if one of the wildest
stories of my whole life was hanging out
with meatloaf at Dave's house Dave
Ramsey's house what
what I will say this um I went home that
night and I told my wife but I won't do
that I said hey
I don't know how to say this but um I
was just hanging out for the last hour
with with meatloaf just me and him I'm
dying and she half asleep she goes did
you find out what that one thing he was
wouldn't be for love is and I was like
who's that that's oh he's so amazing
amazing I'll never forget that night as
long as I live meatloaf said I know
you're looking for a ruby an amount of
rocks but there ain't no Coupe DeVille
at the bottom of a Cracker Jack box why
are you guys doing this they're just
trolling me but I love hey I I love
meatloaf and I asked him hey I can't
call you like meatloaf and he goes no
call me meat and I said I was looking
for like a Dan or a Rick and he's like
nope loaf they call me meat first name
meat one of the most amazing evenings of
my life ever all right let's go out to
uh Tel Aviv Israel and talk to Mike what
up Mike how we doing
hey there thanks for inviting me thank
you so much for calling what's up
um I have a situation that I think is
there also a financial and also a
relationship stuff Let's Do It
um
my wife comes from a pretty wealthy
family and we've been married since like
2018.
and
basically we're now you know in control
of our own finances and you know
building our own
Airline and uh basically I'm just
struggling with uh
overly expenses you know she expect she
expenses her expenses are pretty much
higher than her income hmm
so can I
um can I ask you some direct questions
that I'm going to ask questions that
might sound like a little bit of tacky
but this is just me and you we're
friends okay is that cool can you hear
it that way yeah go ahead
and again I asked this with all due
respect but is she a spoiled brat
she's spoiled but she also in in a lot
of the times next to her she worked two
jobs when she really wanted stuff it's
not taken for granted it's really Brave
to do that sure not a lot of people do
that yeah
morning to night
but
regarding her what she wants what she
wants to buy and stuff like that
she can't really control it I I don't
know if it's addictive but it's a
problem
my so she comes from a wealthy family
how wealthy
um like a couple of millions okay okay
just a couple of Millions
so she's just used to you know a little
bit of an upper lifestyle she can she's
used to eating what she wants going out
when she wants going to the mall getting
what she wants and so now you're like
hey we don't have that kind of money we
haven't earned that yet you gotta cool
out and she's saying no
yeah and we have a baby we just bought a
house like two years ago just after the
pandemic and everything and it's really
crazy Mike have you have you had that
clear conversation with her have you
guys sat down and said
here's what's going on absolutely
absolutely and we've been doing that
like for for four years even before we
bought the house and we went to therapy
for six months and I've been working now
for two jobs and she is working uh one
job and taking care of our baby and
basically my question is should I quit
the job because my job is keeping us
like over the water and if um reading
the second job and when I'm really
really uh putting a lot to do that like
I'm missing my son yeah I'm missing a
lot of stuff and it's really hard
because I'm really connected to family
yeah and I'm missing on hobbies and but
you're not making any traction for it
exactly and appreciation or and a lot of
a lot of times that money that I'm
making for savings is going to the trash
yeah yeah
Mez is hard
um it's not a money problem I'll tell
you that this is not a money problem at
all
um yeah the hardest part about being
married is that it's every single day
and the hardest part about being married
is that it's two people I have to be all
in
and yeah I would even go as far well I
mean you've you've you've checked off
the things that like that I would
initially tell you to do
like your marriage is in trouble you
need to have a direct conversation and
not a direct conversation about you need
to quit spending money like that a
direct conversation like I'm so scared I
can't breathe
exactly we don't make the kind of money
that you grew up with and you're
spending money as though you are
and I'm terrified I'm missing our son
I'm missing my family I can't do this
anymore
if that's a different conversation that
it that is e-centric it's not throwing
grenades at her it's saying I can't live
like this here's what's happening inside
of me
um if you said you've already done that
my guess is that's probably a little
more intimate a little more vulnerable
than you probably had the conversation
earlier they all been talking for years
about the spending and getting under
control and we should have a budget and
you need to quit using credit cards all
that you've probably done that a million
times
the next thing I would tell you is go
get a professional go talk to a
counselor sounds like you all have done
that
um
I would say look at the chaos in your
lives but covid was brutal and you're
part of the world and y'all bought a
house and now you got a kid and you're
working two jobs and you're not home
very often so there's a lot of chaos
inside your house Fair
yeah definitely so
there's there's two paths forward here
one is you have to protect your family
finances and this is a
almost never would I recommend this ever
ever it goes against all of my Core
teaching except in this one moment if
your family finances aren't safe because
you have somebody in your inside your
home that is struggling with some sort
of addiction and they are not taking
steps towards getting well you have to
protect your family
meaning at some point combining finances
is not safe
okay if you're in danger of like let's
say you decided hey we make enough money
if we were to budget and live beneath
our means we make plenty of money to
have a good whole life here without me
having to work 20 hours a day and miss
my entire child's life
and so as a family I we're going to make
this decision I'm out I'm going to work
my one job you're going to work your one
job and we're going to be a two income
family and we're gonna love our life
and if so doing she continued to spend
and y'all are going to get kicked out of
your home you would have to protect your
family by
moving money into a single account okay
you have to start taking protective
measures is what I'm saying
for now we're not combining our bank
accounts okay not combined we were
separated and the mortgage is going off
from a another account that is
uh Mutual okay so is she at this point
is she just racking up debt on credit
cards is that where it's yeah yeah sure
yeah is your is your name is your name
on the credit cards
is your name on the credit cards
my name is not on the credit card but we
have loans going out going off her
account for the house and
it's a problem you know like she can she
can block her own account and I don't
know if it would be any effect on on the
house or something like that but I I
can't live like under the pressure that
I'm going to lose control of my life or
that um have you said that Mike have you
said that
yeah of course we're also going on a
second therapy tomorrow okay starting
tomorrow so here's here's the there's a
this might not be a this might not be a
popular opinion but let me hear you say
this let me let me say this you can
cheat on your spouse with another person
you can cheat on your spouse with a golf
club you can cheat on your spouse with
work you can cheat on your spouse with
finances
and I think going to a second counseling
session and looking at this at your
spouse at your wife and saying this ends
today
I have at my or what moment and or what
is I cannot continue to live under this
stress if you continue to not want to be
a part of this unified relationship
that's her opting out and you're just
calling the truth as it is hard hard
stuff my brother let us know how that
counseling session goes but you need to
be direct and bold and honest Dr John
deloney if you like what you heard in
this episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramseysolutions.com and click on
the get started button will help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]